yeah welcome to get another video
playing love erick one from my grease d
3 okay keep it simple yeah night BTW 7sm
slightly inaccurate but this I can play
out again might be serviced not so great
okay just am developing normally he's
some toying with this idea of playing
night to d6 check let's see yeah come on
keep it simple this is just leading to a
normal simple position
yeah Bishop takes f6 is not especially
great but by play night why play Bishop
g5 in the first place if you are going
to tend to take
yep whatever you you can say about this
guy is playing quickly
yeah it's not not without its points
should I am play a form should be six
not sure about all this yeah this looks
a bit cheeky is this position for Black
Knight f3 it's it's got good player in
the center yeah but Castle he takes you
five well it doesn't look right but to
what what else I'm just playing just
instantly all the time I love that so
not bad even yeah one of the problems
k i'm not sure i thought 'i six would be
an idea weakening my pawn structure now
you know maybe still it's still somewhat
tricky for black but I'm not sure that
this was the most dangerous yeah yeah
Queen g4 at the end why should I take
what the pawn that looks really silly to
take what the pong game take him yeah I
know Quincy forward of taking with the
porn also what sauce quite weird Jim the
Bishop Guth okay
yeah I didn't understand any of those
moves he's playing or everything
instantly and this spirits pretty much
and I know why allow this check don't
understand it yeah I could have played
King be one but it's um it's not so not
so terrible anyway okay
so I didn't really expect that move but
ok why not is helping me to get rid of
my weakness now ya da porn may push the
apron
check
taking a 5-wood check so okay so
something else beside the endgame yeah
probably not okay want to win the pony
of course
I dois I'm such an idiot first aid come
on the only way to not win the game is
this really I was just the my phones are
quicker I just shouldn't blunder it and
now okay I'm toast he can even probably
just sec the look at some point I'm such
an idiot g-form
unfortunately this is so easily winning
that you cannot really spoil it
yeah even that is winning it hmm is
there some trick at least maybe I can
now you can play seven and he will
probably see it it's not exactly
difficult yeah yeah gift time learning
handing out gifts here yeah just silly I
mean this pawns are quicker it's a
problem and stuff like h5 should it
should be just better for like maybe you
can draw as it's possible it's possible
say it's not the thorough analysis of
course you five yeah yeah that's
probably a drawer still something like
this yeah yeah that's probably a drum
but of course g4s is just silly it's
it's giving the game away and just
giving the game away and some are
already had envisioned him that you'd
taken c6 and this is it just just just
silly can also play this on one side of
me losing its really difficult because
as mentioned my pawn is a bit bit more
advanced yeah thanks for watching